Hello.
We're now going to do some more
slope, and then maybe some
y-intercept problems as well.
Let's get started.
So let me make up a problem.
Let's say we have
the points 2, 5.
The other point, let's make
that negative 3, negative 3.
Well, first let's just
graph those two points.
I'm going to graph
them in yellow.
So 2, 5.
Let's see that's one two.
One, two, three, four, five.
So 2, 5 is going to
be right over there.
OK.
And then let me graph
negative 3, negative 3.
So it's one, two, three.
One, two, three.
So negative 3, negative
3 is right over there.
And then now let me draw a
line that will connect them.
That's my new technique.
I draw it in two pieces.
I think that's good enough.
OK.
So let's see if we can at least
first figure out the slope of
the line, and then if we have
time we'll try to figure
out the y-intercept.
And then we'll know the whole
equation for the line.
Let me pick a slightly thinner
color, and we'll get started.
So the slope, if you saw
the last module that just
introduces how we calculate
the slope, that's
just rise over run.
Or, change in y
over change in x.
This is y.
So let's just do
that real fast.
So let's take this as
our starting point.
So change in y could be
5-- remember, y is the
second coordinate--
5 minus negative 3.
And that's this one.
Over-- now you do the change
in x-- 2 minus, this
is also negative 3.
Well 5 minus negative 3,
that's 5 plus plus 3.
So that equals 8.
And then 2 minus negative 3.
Once again that's 2 plus
plus 3, so that equals 5.
So we figured out the
slope of this equation.
It's 8/5.
And let's see if
that makes sense.
Let's figure out what the
rise and the run is.
If we were to start at this
point right here, let's see how
much we have to rise to get to
the same y-coordinate
as the other point.
So let's see.
We're here, and the
other point is up here.
So let's figure out
what this distance is.
Actually, now is a good
time to use the fat.
Oh man, I have a shaky hand.
OK.
Let's figure out what
that distance is.
That distance is delta y,
which is change in y.
So it's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
That equals 8.
And that makes sense, because
if you think about it
what did we just do?
We just took y equals 5,
which was up here, minus
y equals negative 3.
And so obviously we just
calculated that distance
just by looking at the two
coordinates 5 minus negative 3.
When you do this calculation
it actually gives you
this distance right here.
So that's how we figure out
how much we have to rise.
So now let's do the run.
Well the run, to go from
this point to the other
point, we went this far.
And let's count
how far that is.
Well, it's one, two,
three, four, five units.
So we can say delta
x is equal to 5.
And that's exactly what we did.
delta y over delta x was equal
to 8/5, or rise over
run is equal to 8/5.
And it would have been the same
thing if we calculated run here
or if we calculated rise here.
But it's the same thing.
Hope that's making
sense to you.
And I hope that also makes
sense that if the rise for a
given run becomes more, then
the slope of the line is going
to become steeper and it'll
become a bigger number.
So let's see what we
have so far for the
equation of this line.
So so far we know the equation
of this line is equal to, y is
equal to the slope
8/5 x plus b.
So we're almost done.
We just have to figure
out this b right here.
Now that b, just so
you remember, that's
the y-intercept.
And that's where we
intersect the y-axis.
And since this graph is pretty
neat, we can actually inspect
it and see that, well, it looks
like we're intersecting
the y-axis at 2.
So my guess is we're going
to come up with b equals 2.
But let's solve it, just in
case we didn't have this
neatly drawn graph here.
So how can we solve for b?
Well, we can substitute
values that we know
that work for x and y.
Well either of these points
are on that line, so we can
substitute them in for x and y.
So let's use the first one.
OK.
So the y we get 5, will
equal 8/5 times x.
Well, x there is 2.
Times 2 plus b.
Well, now we just get 5
is equal to 16/5 plus b.
And then we get b equals--
well 5 is 25/5, right?
5 is 25/5 minus
16/5 equals 9/5.
All right.
See, so I was actually wrong.
When I looked at this graph
I said, oh that looks like
almost 2, so yeah it's
probably going to be 2.
But when we actually did it
using algebra, when we did it
analytically, we actually
saw that b is equal to 9/5.
So it's almost 2.
9/5 is 1 and 4/5, or 1.8.
So that's almost 2,
but it actually turns
out that it's not.
It's at 1.8.
And I can write it
down as a decimal.
1.8.
So the final equation for the
line, I'm going to try to
squeeze it in at the bottom of
this page, it's going to be y
is equal to-- well,
we know the slope.
8/5 x.
Now we just add
the y-intercept.
Plus 9/5.
There.
We solved it.
Let's do another one.
And so-- that's 9/5.
I don't want to be
too repetitive.
Let's do another problem.
Time to do another problem,
and let me put that
graph back there again.
There you go.
All right.
I'm going to think of two
random numbers again.
Let me try to do this fast,
because YouTube puts a
10 minute limit on me.
So let's say I had the
points 2, negative 3.
And I had the point
negative 4, 5.
So 2, negative 3.
Let's plot that
sucker real fast.
So x is 2, so it's here.
And the negative 3.
One, two, three.
So 2, negative 3 is there.
And negative 4, 5.
So that's one,
two, three, four.
One, two, three, four, five.
I have to count like
this because this
graph is unlabeled.
But if we actually were to draw
in the coordinates you would
that see this is 5, and this
is negative 4, and so on.
And this is 2, and
this is negative 3.
And now let's just draw a line.
Let's draw it right there
with my shaky hand.
OK.
There you go.
Good line.
And another good line.
All right.
So first we need to
figure out the slope.
Well we could just do
that doing the algebra.
So its slope is just delta--
I'm still using the line tool
again-- delta y over delta x.
Change in y over change in x.
Let's take this y as
the first point now.
So we'll say 5 minus
this y, negative 3.
Over-- now since we used the
5 first we have to use the
negative 4 first as well.
Negative 4 minus 2.
Well 5 minus negative
3, that equals 8.
And negative 4 minus 2, well
that equals negative 6.
And negative 8/6, well
that equals-- they're
both divisible by 2.
So that equals minus 4/3.
And let's see, does that
make sense as the slope?
Well, if we were to go down
four from this point.
So if the rise was negative
4-- one, two, three, four.
So if we go down--
woops, I'm using white.
So that's why you can't see it.
We go down by four here, and
then we go to the right
three, positive 3.
We still end up on the line.
So it works.
Looks good to me.
Let's see if I can solve the
y-intercept in 30 seconds.
Otherwise, I'll start
it on the next module.
So we get y is equal to
minus 4/3 x, plus b.
And actually what we'll do is
we'll leave off here, and I'm
going to solve for b-- and you
could try to do it on your
own-- in the next installment
of this presentation.